ولمتابعه الوضع معنا من الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره جيفاره البديري جيفارا لك
كلمه فيما يتعلق بالوضع من طرف الجليل
الاعلى نعم قبل قليل سمح بالنشر وافادت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه رسميه ان مسيره
اطلقت من داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه
واسقطت في معسكر القياده الشماليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي الواقع بالقرب من مدينه صفط
التي تبعد عن خط الحدود مع لبنان نحو 20 ك
مر هذه ليست
بالقاعده الصغيره هي وحسب وصف وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه نتحدث عن قياده
المنطقه الشماليه بالكامل في الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه لم يعلن ان كان
هناك اصابات وا لكن واضح ان حاله التوتر
تزداد شيئا فشيئا على طول خط الحدود مع
لبنان من داخل الجليل والان اصبحنا نتحدث
عن ما هو ابعد فقط من ثمان كيلو مترات
خلال الساعه الماضيه دوت صافرات الانذار
في اكثر من 30 موقعا وبلده على طول خط
الحدود وصولا الى مدينه صفد وذلك نتيجه
الصواريخ التي اطلقت من داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه وايضا كان هناك تحذيرات من
مسيرات تتسلل عبر الحدود من لبنان اتجاه
مواقع وبلدات اسرائيليه بالطبع المعلومات
لازالت شحيحه حول استهداف هذه
القاعده الاسرائيليه لانه عاده ما يتم
الاعلان عن هذه المعلومات بشكل متاخر وا
ليس على الفور اذا ما تم تاكيده من قبل اي
ال الرقابه العسكريه بانه سمح بالنشر
باستهداف قاعده قياده المنطقه الشماليه في
مدينه صفد وهذه القاعده واضح انها من
القواعد الرئيسيه والمركزيه في شمالي
اسرائيل بالطبع الاحداث تصاعدت وبدات توتر
يزداد شيئا فشيئا بعد اي الاستهداف الاخير
ل الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما استهدف وسام
الطويل الذي اعتبر من قبل مسؤولين
اسرائيليين
وعسكريين تحديدا بانه الشخصيه الاهم عمليا
في داخل حزب الله ومسؤول عن عده عمليات
نفذها حزب الله حتى تم العوده الى تاريخه
بمعنى العوده الى عام 2006 بانه من ابرز
من شاركوا في عمليه خطف ال الجنود في
لبنان والذي ادى هذا الحدث الى اندلاع
الحرب عام 2006 بين اسرائيل ولبنان بالامس
يعني رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيمين
نتنياهو حذر حزب الله بشكل مبطن وقال ان
اسرائيل كان يقول عنها الحزب انها اوهن من
البيت العنكبوت لكن اسرائيل ترد بشكل اي
هائل وقوه هائله وبان الحزب ارتكب خطا عام
2006 وهو يقوم الان بارتكاب ذات ال الخطا
وانه يقدم الان لحزب الله مثال صارخ لما
يحدث لاصدقائه حسب وصف نتنياهو اي ما يحدث
في قطاع غزه من دمار وتدمير كامل للقطاع
والمجازر التي ترتكب هناك ال هذه الاجواء
المشحونه جدا تاتي في خضم الزياره
الدبلوماسيه التي يقوم بها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن خاصه ان الاداره
الامريكيه تحاول نزع فتيل اندلاع حرب
فعليه ما بين اسرائيل ولبنان لانه حسب وصف
الاداره الامريكيه ذلك سيؤدي الى اشتعال
المنطقه
بالكامل وبالتالي هو يحاول الان تهدئه
الاوضاع ولكن اسرائيل استقبلت بلينكن
باستهداف وسام الطويل داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه وب وبعد ذلك استهدفت من وصفته
بالمسؤول المركزي عن اطلاق الصواريخ في
حركه حماس من داخل الاراضي السوريه واليوم
خلال اجتماع بلينكن مع المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين تم استهداف ايه سياره في
داخل الجنوب اللبناني طائرات حربيه لا
تفارق الاجواء على الاطلاق على طول خط
الحدود تحديدا في الجليل واصبع الجليل
وبالقطع الثلاث الاوسط والغربي والشرقي
نسمع بين الفينه والاخرى دوي قذائف
الدبابات تطلق من الحدود مع لبنان الى
داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه